dire qualitatif on va partir sur un
stream qualitatif les amis et on va se
faire le king of the hill comme comme
promis en fait je lui ai dit qu'on s'en
ferait un comme ça demain ce sera le 960
avec fab comme on va voir s'il est
vraiment fort en 960 et est donc on va
se faire le king of the hill roi de la
colline roi de la montagne on ne sait
plus et on va appeler çà comme arena
king of the hill je vais pas me planter
je mets trois de la colline on va mettre
3 + 2 on va mettre aujourd'hui on va
vers 3h15 et on va mettre 60 minutes
parce que bordel j'ai le droit et 0
partie minimum on va ouvrir le chat il
est déjà ouvert il n'y a personne
apparemment on va un peu discuté un
comme d'hab' tranquillou pekouz pekouz
les amis paix pouces de chez p pouze et
pousse c'est le mot épouse c'est le mot
qu'on veut entendre
p12 salut l'ofce salut à tous et hier
soir c'était vraiment longue et dans les
gars maintenant pour revenir dessus tu
vois on a on a quand même le droit
bordel de parler de ce qui s'est passé
de ce tournoi d'hier franchement c'était
loin un moment donné ça m'a ça m'a un
peu overdose et n'en sais pas vous mais
moi je trouve à un moment donné ça a été
long juste genre trop long genre note
vraiment trop long ça lui fait un enfant
qui fn salut aristo farka salut qui
donne ce qu'on le kiosque a décidé de
pas me répondre
qu'est ce qui se passe là que j'ai
passées jusqu'au bout mais c'était trop
long ça lui cyril of merlin c'était
vraiment longue chez nous hier
franchement en fête les 20 ans soit la
phase finale aurait pu être pas mal mais
à un moment donné tu peux pas en faire
un évène comme ça sur six heures
d'affilée
tu m'aime moi j'ai décroché un moment
donné je pouvais
plus je me bouffer des giclées d'échec à
un moment donné je pouvais plus juste
j'ai essayé de bien commenté quand même
hein je me suis battu je pense j'ai
quand même fait du commentaire de
qualité pour les demies et pour la
finale mais à un moment donné c'était il
y avait trop de matchs c'était c'était
c'était too much
je trouve que c'est dommage qu'il n'ait
pas fait la phase finale ce soir en fait
ça s'est extrêmement huawei s'est testé
trois m'ont donné très clairement je
sais pas quel bon je pense j'ai un peu
dekra décroché sur les quarts de finale
et je suis revenu dans pour pour les
deux mines en est le match pour la
troisième place n'a fait très très mal
je crois que le match pour la troisième
place m'a achevé ouais je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont partis à un
moment donné et je vous comprends
je vous mettre le lien du tournoi
d'aujourd'hui
donc on va se refaire le king of the
hill mais normalement la nappe en effet
qu'une demi heure
c'est la goutte d'eau qui a mis le feu
aux poudres ah ouais c'était c'était
vraiment le le truc de trop dans mon
opinion s'est passé quoi mais ouais
vraiment juste déçu que ça va être effet
sur nos jours parce que les phases
finales qui était finalement le truc le
plus intéressant le truc était plus
intéressant qui étaient les phases
finales finalement c'est surtout les 2
me et les finales qui avait il y avait
des affiches qui était pas mal mais
c'est arrivé après tellement d'échec le
principe de king of the hill cyril afs
est d'amener le roi sur une de ces
quatre cases rouges
je les laissais en rouge
marc mais six heures c'est loin même la
finale du super bowl qui a un truc super
long ça dure ça dure 4 avec le concert
de beyoncé au milieu c'est ce dont
parlait pendant pour ceux qui ont pas
suivis jusqu'au bout et et ça dure que
quatre heures avec le concert de beyoncé
ou de chez pas quoi au milieu et tout ce
spectacle là la compet elle a duré six
heures mais aussi manqué de gros noms
dans la phase finale
honnêtement tu aurais eu un haka ou
untel ou tu vois quelqu'un comme ça ça
aurait beaucoup plus hype et le truc ça
13h15 le king of the hill mais y'a
personne pour le moment dans le tournoi
casino est à retenir finalement qui a
gagné le tournoi contre pornic mais tu
vois ça ça il ya eu ça aussi qui était
un peu dommage c'est que ça passe a pas
fait de grosses de grosses affiches et
qu'est-ce que je tends la victoire de
pierrot déjà écoute je pense que tout le
monde en fait tout un foin quoi je vois
ça sur facebook quoi ça reste un match
amical sur internet fin tu vois fin
toute raison garder quoi c'est un bon
résultat mais après il est quand même
très rapide à la souris
donc je sais pas il faut il faut raison
garder mes premiers échos de quatre là
dans le tournoi lise avec cette année à
deux clubs et je crois que l'acceptation
allait aller direct la justice j'ai vu
des gars à qui parler de tournant
historique hier sur twitter normes et
les gens raconte vraiment n'importe quoi
apple par mgr faut arrêter un moment
donné passé comme si à un moment donné
tu as un gars 16 ans qui met deux petits
ponts à l'entraînement sur un défenseur
tu vois enfin gérard moment donné c'est
du blitz est pas la même cadence
c'est un truc spécial s'est même pas
officielle fars tu auras jugent pas
assez cool c'est ça veut dire qu'il est
très doué il confirme mais j'étais plus
sur le cul l'an dernier quand il finit
troisième du championnat du monde de
blitz août chez plus quoi à 15 ans que
est là cette année il avait confirmé
j'en avais parlé déjà en décembre quand
on avait commandé 100 directs au
championnat du monde de blitz est rapide
il était impressionnant en fait
fallait il exagère pour faire du buzz
mais oui c'est comme si le pouilly gagne
à l'entraînement contre nadal en amical
quoi un moment donné il faut un match
amical sur sur un terrain d'entraînement
et ça arrive et pouilly gagne 1,7
d'ailleurs dans ma région il ya eu un
des match amical de préparation
reconnaissait medvedev le joueur de
tennis peut être bon il a fait que fait
il habite à cannes il s'entraîne à
cannes et avant le masters de londres il
a organisé un
des matches amicaux entre guillemets
pour se chauffer pour le tournoi de
londres et il avait perdu contre un mec
est 150e français et ça se joue à la
bocca pas loin de chez moi et il a perdu
genre 7 6 dans le tie break du deuxième
ou du troisième set je sais plus ah et
il paraît qu'il a cassé sa raquette
carrément à la sortie du match il est
parti genre très très énervés du truc
mais est ce que ça veut dire que le 150e
français va jouer dans le top 10 mondial
d'ici quelques jours non pas du tout et
ça a pas fait un buzz international dans
le monde du tennis oui il a gagné ce
match amical ça veut sûrement dire qu'il
est très très fort bon ok je sais pas
quel et à kehl pour il a pris le match
au sérieux tu en sais rien farm ont en
gros c'est très bizarre c'est eux
bah ouais c'est un match amical j'ai pas
l'impression qu'au foot côté nice que
dans tous les jeux et sports normaux
quand quelqu'un gagne un match amical on
en fasse un tel foin mais bon aux échecs
j'ai l'impression que moi il a gagné un
bus amical la chance
non je pense juste que l'échec on est
très très con quoi perugia il a fait
déjà des choses qui sont beaucoup plus
impressionnante que ça à ses résultats
aux championnats du monde de beats et
rapide sur les deux dernières sessions
c'est clairement un top 10 mondial de
beats et rapide à 16 ans c'est très
clairement un top 10 mondial
et ça c'est sûr un vrai échiquier et
c'est dans des compétitions officielles
et c'est hyper intéressant qu'un top 10
mondial sur un match amical battre le
numéro un mondial
ma foi c'est plus que possible saharien
de d'extraordinaire tu vois j'ai pas ta
marine cilici en matin à mach amical va
federer je parle un peu de dire quelques
années ok c'est pas super surprenant en
fait ça peut arriver évidemment fait des
favoris mais bon si leach plus amicales
machin ya pas faim
c'est tout après tant mieux tant mieux
pour lui qu'il ait gagné et ça confirme
ce qu'on savait déjà qu'il est très
talentueux nanani nanana même et là tu
vas sur twitter tu as l'impression que
et si tu as déjà gagné l'us open oui oui
mais voilà du coup pour résumer bravo à
lui mais sais pas on verra on verra
quand confinement s'arrête quand les
vrais tournant reprennent ce qui était
intéressant aussi est très instructif
c'était la victoire de carlos n en
longues contre fil rouge à availles
kenzy si vous vous rappelez ça c'est
instructif parce que là on pensait que
firent au jaï pouvez commencer à venir
titiller karl scène en longues donc du
coup sur le terrain important en tournée
officielle et magnus l'avait bien sécher
après firoud déjà ça va être à mon avis
un énorme problème pour magnus d'ici
quatre ans à mon avis dans deux ou
quatre ans ce sera un vrai vrai vrai
souci farruggia s'il continue sur cette
pente d'ascension on va mon avis avoir
le droit à un match firoud
giant-carlisle scène et ça va faire très
très mal
ça va être c'est celui qui peut lui
prendre le titre très très très
clairement et évidemment deux ou quatre
pattes rouabah ouais après ça dépend
c'est avec le coffre avec le co vide les
matchs sont dans 3 ans et parce que du
coup peut-être qu'il ya une année qui va
sauter
donc c'est ça c'est ça honnêtement qui
va être très intéressant et c'est là que
c'est là qu'on va voir vraiment son
évolution à pierrot déjà il peut aussi
complètement craqué du jour au lendemain
en fin gère un moment donné on ne sait
pas quoi fin souvent à cet âge là ce qui
peut commencer au cias arriver parfois
c'est que bon bain à 16 17 18 ans tu
peux te rendre contrat il n'y a pas que
les échecs dans la vie il ya d'autres
choses très intéressantes bien plus
intéressante que je ne l'aurais imaginé
voilà j'ai pas trop quoi tu parles bon
j'ai entendu des rumeurs
et ça ça peut aussi faire un changement
majeur est dans la tête et machin après
il ya des gens qui s'en foutent
totalement aux siens c'est vrai que il a
aussi un ajout voilà et puis peut ne
plus aimer les échecs du jour au
lendemain se passionnait pour d'autres
choses je sais pas dans le deuxième
cerveau série la fois exactement le
cerveau beaucoup plus important peut se
mettre à penser à d'autres choses quoi
donc on verra
je suis une trajectoire à vlad a
exactement la tient peu suivi cette
trajectoire est un moment donné il a
sûrement compris qu' il ya des choses
plus intéressantes que les échecs
je n'y avais jamais pensé est ce
qu'elles veulent peut être premier
mondial est possible mais justement et
en iran l'alcool et favorise des
distractions dangereuse mais le truc
c'est qu'il est venu vivre en france
donc à tout moment il peut se dire mais
peut-être que ce n'est pas si dangereux
que ça et se rendre compte qu'en fait si
c'était vraiment très dangereux en fait
tout le monde sait tout le monde est au
courant
donc on verra il est encore jeune faut
lui laisser le temps à que 16 ou 17 ans
les gens
il a le temps on verra appui qui te dit
que ian sarine va pas tout d'un coup
explosé plus que lui qui te dit qu'un
prague ananda a pas un potentiel énorme
caché qu' il va arriver à travailler son
sont n ous on n oublie pas comment
t'appelles ça dans les mangas et que
tout d'un coup il est devenu beaucoup
plus fort très vite quand on n'en sait
rien c'est pas ou 1 marquant ou en
matériaux j'en sais rien moi ou des
jeunes dont on connaît même pas le nom
encore maintenant qui explose tout d'un
coup et qui deviennent tu sais pas en
vrai
tu sais pas évidemment il est
impressionnant
il ya comme une fille qui va débarquer
tout défoncer non je n'ai pas encore
mais je suis que saison 4 pour le moment
je moment ils sont dans greed island
j'aurai mes liens vers le tournoi
et on m'a dit que l'arc sur les fourmis
sté nullissime du coup c'est vrai ou
c'est pas vrai non je prendre on verra
bon j'ai du mal à me concentrer je pense
que c'était plutôt que trois au québec
il est très bien que les gens m'ont
montreuil et l'art sur guide island vous
avez aimé ou pas bon je vais faire grand
roque et je vais envoyer les lions pain
était je suis content parce que m'a
peut-être ma montée je vous rappelle que
c'est du du king of the hill et ma
montée droit peut arriver jeunes est le
pion à trois ça évitera de me le faire
manger et je vais faire flamber cinq c4
était aussi une option
pas sûr que vous bien
non mais c'est vraiment pas mal un tarif
center vraiment
faut juste passer la première saison est
peut-être la saison 3 m'a moins plu
aussi l'arc sur cour appliqua joue
vraiment mal
l'ars eu recours applicables à tête -
plus
le début du 1 c'est un peu long non mais
il est bien un truc sur coup rapliq a
peut-être un poil longuet
c'est un poil long seulement enfin il
faut que je me concentre moi je joue je
joue du gros caca
non rien ne s'est passé pas vraiment
mauvais il y as tu sautes de mieux et
moins bien mais il n'y a rien de
vraiment mauvais ce que je peux faire
c'est 5
je suis pas du tout concentré
c'est un vieux mangane tarik center je
vois pas trop quoi enfin je suis pas
spécialiste des mangas du coup mais les
personnages sont assez cool moi j'aime
bien kirwa comme personnage tu le
trouves vraiment cool crois que je suis
vraiment pas bien
donc il faut qu'à un bon personnage de
cire est
il se carrer assez marrant
j'aime pas trop parce qu'ils contrôlent
mieux le centre que moi et du coup c'est
très relou la tête dû aller en a cinq
je voulais un peu contrôle f5
je veux reprendre une fois en une fois
ici
faire ces cas qui va pas être terrible
je fais un truc marrant surtout prend
des caches le prenant des 5 ce qui
pourrait donner une position marrante ce
qui bouge le fou et je prends ces six
mêmes s'ils un échec fait roi b1 et
matour et protégés je pense je vais
faire ça il prend des caches condé cinq
amis peut prendre b2 je prends b2i
reprend des cinq nord je vais pas faire
çà il prend des cas tu prends des katas
il prend pas des 4 je peux pas prendre
f5 là en vrai il peut pas apprendre j'ai
fouillé les quatre amis peut commencer
parfois f4 roi b1 et oui et je suis
foutu american iii encore j'avais pas vu
mais j'ai quelques 3 j'ai de la chance
là on est sur des cas je dois avoir ok
il prend la caisse et pleutre ça
c'est l'autre
je souhaite faire un truc beau mais y'a
rien je vais refuser car c'est plus
logique prendre des cinq prendre g4
quelques pommiers que c'est du king of
the hill
non je ferdane des cats et surtour la
tour prends
qu'ai je fait un échec ici un échec ici
ah [ __ ] je gagne la tour ah merde j'ai
joué comme un vrai échec je gagne la
tour mais il avance son pion ok je vais
là d'amoureux 5 et je vais faire dame
prend des quatre oui je pense qu'il
devait tenter d 3 et maintenant je
bloque la colonne des jeux blocs sont
rois et je vais analyser après je pense
était hyper intéressant de pousser des
trois et je sais pas et j'avais
peut-être tour f1 des deux reste est
intéressant ce que là ok il encaisse la
dame et il revoit jamais les casses
centrale mais on est là d'un médecin que
je pense était très bien joué ce que
deux badges pensée d'anne decis mais
après d'apprendre et si on prend des six
rondes et si je peux plus bloquer les
deux cases et du coup ces perdants donc
dames 5 menace dame prend des cats pour
bloquer la je pensais détroit et
j'imagine maintenant peut-être tour f1
avec l'idée tour f 6 1 et mais c'est
chaud ce qui a peut-être d'amd 5
maintenant à mesdames des cinq tours f5
ouais je dois pouvoir maintenir
shaw can il avait dame contours dans la
partie avec moi mon père du temps par
rapport au point le programme des trois
promotions était une option du coup je
pense la dame rose 5 est vraiment très
bien placé ce que je veux la mettre en
d4 et je bloque les cases avant le
gambit hypothèse d'un grand dam ouais
mais si fait dame prend dame là je fais
tout reprend roi prend et tour des uns
autour des 2 et je bloque
il viendra jamais sur les cases centrale
mais mon idée c'est roy d un deux trois
ou quatre alors attends juste faut que
je checke un autre ex que si je suis
numéro un mondial du jeu où j'arrête
peut-être un haut niveau le tournoi et
jaurès numéro un mondial à vita aeternam
ça c'est un autre truc qu'il faut que
vous compreniez quoi c'est où les
meilleurs placements de king of the hill
je trouve plus si vous avez un lien
chaque jour je suis numéro un mondial je
ne joue plus quoi je remets je prends un
des risques à chaque partie que je joue
bien c'est insupportable
ou envoyez moi si vous pouvez refait une
partie
on attendait alors je suis numéro 5 et
les gens qui me sont passés devant
j'étais numéro 4 i hier il ya un grand
maître iranien qui m'est passé devant
je suis 5e j'ai reculé
allez je suis très loin du premier le
premier il a hélas 3000 et qalqilya une
toutes ces parties après peut-être il
s'est arrangé aussi
salut countryman non mais le jour où je
suis niveau mondial j'arrête tout quoi
je ne suis plus du tout intéressé par le
jeu est en train de me faire défoncer je
n'ai pas très bien joué
voilà
on va voir
on apprend mais un peu dans le caca j'ai
l'impression
je peux prendre en ces lieux et prendre
trois
et bien placé la dame 3 les carriers
sont sur blanc donc au prochain coup tu
y joues il contrôle des cases blanches
donc madame est inattaquable hockey
plutôt heureux d'échanger
ça va aller mais oui je suis encore loin
de des leaders le fond ces six ans des
six
enfin que je fasse très attention à la
montée du roi celui de s'amener l'euro
sans toi je vais grand roque est fou
jécistes était ce une option aussi
mais la moindre les règles c'est de
ramener le roi sur une de ces quatre
cases mais la moindre défaite peut me
faire mal fait la moindre défaite et je
perds toute chance de de monthey je
parle à 260 points si je perdais contre
ce jour là
mais petit à petit la position a l'air
de s'améliorer
vraiment je fais juste attention que son
rap us pas monter mon avantage matériel
au centre avec meilhon qui sont bien au
juste jouer normalement monsieur pessoa
faut pas se prendre la tête mais à la
fin peut-être t'amène le roi mais faut
surtout pas se prendre la tête avec le
roi faire un échec
il abandonne à requiert encore way f1
c'était loin d'être fait tu peux gagner
qu'un point encore et pourquoi je perds
370 points si je perds contre lui alors
qu'il a plus des lots que le garde avant
ma ans
je prends ici de reprendre la lame
jetez-y ces trois dames à 5 jeux
développés puisque ça vaut ch'ti soir
avec la demande des trois trucs sur le
catch fait d'après 4 sur échec ce qui
est assez agréable
là tu voulais jouer des 5
ok je reprends du lion
fa
caisse et chaude chez shaw bon j'arrive
pas trop évaluer ce truc là
ce truc si on échoue avec normand fou 17
vous prend 17 e reprend 17 qui est prend
1,5
ça gagne mais layar wade si ce qui est
probable c'est trois des cinq as tu
pouvais te faut jouer comme en échec
normaux mais le truc c'est que parfois
tu as le gain mais ça gagne plus du tout
je vais prendre une fois quand même et
je vais être le pion c4 et le pion 4
parce qu'il menace et leucate et site
the cat je vais faire piéger 5 ok il
veut faire ça mais là dessus je fais 3 e
ok puis on prend 1 4 et 1 faisable que
j'ai roi de 3 fin de la partie et donc
ses shows de knight il peut faire être
quatre pour tous fermés mais du coup je
fais tes proches 4 et je reviens vers f5
ok ça c'est bien joué
ce un très bon coup oui je joue un truc
qui aurait marché en échec vrai mais qui
n'a pas marché du tout ici j'ai fait roi
détroit quand même surpris on prend au
roi prend ça c'est évident et mon idée
c'est de faire tour un nas est
intéressant c'est hyper tactique
ouais je fais retour un arrêté prend 1,5
et pas une menace que roy prend ça gagne
si tu as comme jeu
quel quartier des 4
ok je prends tour f4
je comprends pas trop le délire je fais
retour ici qui est prend des 5
ok je vais faire car et b5 et chaque
point f4 je vais m'asseoir 4 il doit
faire tout reprend et tout reprendre 5
c'était pas terrible et peut-être tours
qu'est-ce qui avait quatre échecs
peut-être
j'ai dû rater un truc auquel siph nuls
c'est la personne la plus haute de
l'univers connaissent pas possible
j'aurai une variante et faire nul sais
c'est moche quoi
pas tenu bien jouer faire tout reprend
1,5 jeu las de nouveau devenir en quatre
mois je pense je vais gagner parce que
je classe 3e cat et je laisse tout
reprendre et cinq lancements qui l'a pas
fait nul il n'a pas été plus être blavot
bravo à lui
non il est pas trop le choix il devait
faire nul mais bon je suis si longtemps
que je dis qu'il est plus trucy fait nul
peut être il meurt il ne fera pas quoi
c'était du semi bluff mais oui il était
obligé de faire mais bon s'il écoute il
va dire oui je suis pleutre je n'ai pas
le droit de faire nul et est par contre
la bonne nouvelle c'est que j'en dépassé
à wesley so il a bien joué way
complètement mais bon il s'est fait pas
une game et part si tu fais nul tu es
pleutre et après un gros coup de
pression et bah ouais mais bon tu n'as
pas envie d'être pleutre quoi à des
propositions nul dans l'autre partie sur
laquelle on se paie qu un banquet ça
c'est quand même une dame c'est cool et
maintenant je vais changer
c'est quand même cool
c'est quand même cool une gamme de plus
mais attendez je suis devant wesley
julien vaillant des cinq pas classe le
roi trop monter on sait jamais que bon
ça c'est pas grave
faut pas te laisse le roi trot monté
c'est j'avais plus d'avancé face à kiev
ouais je suis devant wesley ce qui est
une bonne nouvelle
du coup j'ai d'autant plus peur de
perdre qu'avant comme vous ayez une
défaite est quasiment rédhibitoire quoi
la moindre défaite est rédhibitoire je
veux gagner gagner gagner quelques
places damage trois dames g2 sur pions
pranger dame prend échec avec la tour ça
va faire mal c'est sûr
bon là c'est sûr camatte d'en mettre
trois dames g2 allez on continue à
gagner les points
donc attendez faut que faut que je le
regarde le classement
j'en suis où je suis à trois points du
top 3 après je suis très loin donc en
gros faut que l'on gagne 2 faut que je
regagne 2 parties après je suis top 3 on
fait un screenshot pour pour twitter
vous quelqu'un fait le screenshot
maintenant c'est jamais que je perde
ah non mais là je gagne 0.3 c'est fini
je gagne 0.29 ses victoires
par contre je peux perdre masse de
points le gie qui a battu dragon's aux
dragons mode suicide après sa défaite
contre ludwig
on va voir
je sais par ok pour le plaisir du geste
si je peux
oublie que ce n'étaient pas de vrais
échecs bref attaquant même perdu conclut
dick quoi fabriquer chaque ou pas à
n'importe quel jeu auquel tu perds
contre ludique te ment sueur non demain
ses 960 tu penses mais demain ça avec
fab
je suis très heureux je l'a enfin me
reposer
à midi même si ça me fait plaise le soir
surtout là il ya du try hard avoir une
part toujours à vendre des légumes et
moi aussi lui et moi aussi tous peuvent
1,9
mais le problème c'est que je suis mis
en sueur parle par le try hard de merde
j'avais oublié qu'il pouvait prendre de
la dame à ce moment là ah je me suis
planté
en 1960 rien pas de prépa ouverture plus
de jeu rennes le truc c'est que je vais
attaquer un lâche au taquet dans le king
of the hill
je veux pas perdre je suis chaud je veux
faire top 3 quoi mais on trois mille
3000 3043 c'est quoi ces labels ce mec
qui s'appelle tofig mais tu peux pas
voir combien ajoute partie en king of
the hill donnent des cours pour 30
dollars de la dette au fini mais il fut
en king of the hill contre des mecs qui
sont 2007
ok why not je regarde son profit la cote
r
le trail try hard des shows j'aurais pas
dû mettre leur ajoute ans pour les
pleutres un jeu pas défier des grands
maîtres ils vont me battre ouais monter
le roi dès le début c'est les vrais
joueurs quoi moi je suis un petit joueur
voilà l'adversaire commence à monter le
roi bravo bon après il va vite reculé
c'est bon quoi les votants recettes ont
remonté le roi palmarès du roi de retour
dans huit par le cavalier mais bon il il
a joué dans l'esprit quoi c'était
marrant son recettes bordel j'ai le
droit d'augmenter
maintenant tu n'as pas le droit
des cours de king's day mais est
complètement par le truc c'est que si je
gagne plus de points
non mais je gagne plus de points déjà qu
est ce qui me fait ils montrent laura
direct en fait rien à [ __ ] je fais un
échec enfin les couettes m'en fous amer
jeffers t3f 2 et perdent plein j'aime
prendre hu a eu 5 mc réellement très
dangereux en fait
j'ai failli j'ai vraiment failli perdre
en fait c'est peut-être la partie
n'était plus en danger
j'étais à un coût de gaffer bon c'était
très mal joué en soi n'est finalement
c'est le joueur qui m'a mis le plus en
danger
j'étais à une demi seconde de perdre tes
preuves de rois au 5 mai c'est très
dangereux en fait à la je peux regagner
deux points en fait c'est très très
dangereux j'ai même pas vu que c'était
toi et tu m'as mis en grand danger 1
tu m'as mis en énorme dangereux tous ces
gens qui vivent cette variante
maintenant
je la ressens que les fous sont plus
forts que les cavaliers à ce jeu parce
que c'est tellement important de
contrôler le centre en fin de partie
j'ai cette impression la danse assez
bizarre ce qui me donne la colonne bon
allez normalement je ferais petit rock
et j'ai envie de jouer au vrai jeu pas
je monte déjà un peu le droit ça le met
en sueur je pense m au vert même à ce
jeu là mais bon j'ai envie de m'amuser
aussi sèchement égouts comme c'est ça ou
autre problématique mais vous avec leurs
ouailles touchera jamais le centre
mais bon j'ai envie de jouer dans
l'esprit aussi quoi je vais te la dame
en a 7
mc que je suis bien loin de pouvoir
monter au centre avec le roi
et je sais prendre comme ça j'ai piqué
en des cinq sens très calme très bloquée
mais c'est vrai que je pense les fous
sont plus dominants salaire bien jouer
prendre du coup en baisse 6 voilages
échange les dames et je vais mettre la
tour ambert
bon mes pions faut un bon blocus aussi
calme
je devrais avoir mon petit pion de plus
à l'ancienne allez mon petit pion de
plus je suis heureux c'est un peu mon
roi je suis heureux aussi
c'est vrai que je lis mobilise bien ok
finir là avec le kava sur des cinq c5 et
du coup le centre serait complètement
verrouillé là du coup les quatre cases
centrales sont complètement bloqués mais
j'aime lyon de plus j'ai le lion de plus
je vais prendre des cinq jeux proposent
les changes et je préparais des quatre
pour passer le roi aller c'est gagné 28
66 j'avais mon petit ion de plus le
concept du roi est une pièce en finale
prend tout son sens soit et où
screenshot tafer le screenshot mais je
suis toujours pas top 3 non je suis
toujours quatre frères et un screenshot
a déjà envoyé le mois si jamais qu'on
puisse partager sur twitter sur les
réseaux mais je veux faire top 3 3e
ah non ça ne rapporte pas de points ça
donc le roi très tôt
tenter de bien contrôler les cases
j'aurais pu prendre la dame direct mais
je vais prendre maintenant je vais
monter mon roi
et c'est gagné il peut plus empêcher la
soit l'un soit l'autre
j'ai pas des points à chaque fois
puisque à une trop grande trop grande
différence et l'eau allait en fait tu
pars mauvais à ce jeu je pense
ils me font peur ce qui va être le roi
vite devant qui vont vite le roi non je
regagne 0 point un bordel donnez moi des
adversaires qu'ils me donnent des points
quoi peut-être plus personne ne peut me
donner de point dans ce tournoi plus un
allemand
je passe ça change grand chose les
allemands ils sont dangereux toujours
joue bien ou variante les allemands
généralement je sais pas pourquoi une
culture du jeu en variante je le sens
dangereux quoi
c'est un joueur dangereux là
je sens un danger
je poussais le pian
je mette la tour en dea
je faire g3 quand même le ranger deux
jeux faire h3 je connaissais dû en
fermer un peu la dame
je n'arrive pas vraiment je fais à pied
des trois quilles et t4
j'ai commencé par h3 je vais te fait
cavalier en d4
mais bon pas si simple
j'ai plus trop de pièces pour réussir à
ramener le roi en d4 mais bon je pense
paris vii ce pas terrible parce que son
roi il n'a pas trop axé occase avancer
c'est plutôt le mien qui peu plus tard
dans la partie se diriger j'ai encaissé
un pion quand même j'avais une mauvaise
idée
et après comme ça je fais un des quatre
des cinq je vais aller prendre le
contrôle de cases plus avancé ben
franchement c'était vraiment pas très
bien joué pour une fois la ola
qu'ai je prends ici
d'accord un an sage en caisse
une tour en d1 une tour en vain
des quatre c4 le seul comptait jouer à 4
et ce char wave 3
ça
ça j'avais pas vu j'ai pu pousser 4 ici
je faire tourner un [ __ ] c'est perdu
j'ai oublié des quatre c'est mort j'ai
oublié ça c'est mort fini on a perdu 300
points aïe aïe aïe j'aurais dû jouer
plus 1 j'aurais dû faire pousser 4bet
mans et tours prend des 5
et c'était fini je les ai vus en plus
très vite
adjacent mondiale ouais ça devait
arriver un ouais bon c'est pas grave
adieu le classement mondial
bon voilà je vous complètement n'importe
comment maintenant fini plus aucune
motivation à voir si tout le pays me
bats j'étais super content
c'est vrai perdent vite fait
alors si paul pierce et un matin doit
être foutu et perdant quelques coups on
verra on va voir s'il réussi à mater
d'aller jouer à fond dans l'esprit
je veux faire flamber set peut-être
c'est bien joué il va chasser mon roi et
il va gagner
ça va gagner rapidement pour lui du
combat retombe à 2000 2100
comme ça je fais cadeau en a peut-être
on s'en sort un petit peu parce que du
coup on bloque on lui bloquent l'accès
on lui prend le cavale
je vais le mettre en échec une fois et
je vais prendre là et je dois faire roi
des deux puisque pions prend 1
c'était mon idée il avait peur de se
faire prendre sur échec alors que en
réalité ce n'était pas si grave alors ce
pion faut qu'ils survivent quelques
mètres le quéré villa et bloqué la
montée du roi avec effroi f5 après ça je
bloque la montée du roi à ces dommages à
partie contre l'allemand
la déception est là surtout poussé
katsav a gagné surtout que vous c'est
qu'à gagner
par plusieurs oem mais après ça va je
vous rassure
j'essaye de try hard pourra pour vous
amuser un peu aussi
marc ferro six tours ces huit ballons
pour menacer de prendre ici et devenir
la poule b je vais donner la partie
pourtant l'a pas prise à reprendre ici
je prends ici je veux vraiment avoir
accès à des cinq essais gagner c'est
choc pour tout le pays ouais même fou
bien mais surtout tous ses cadres allez
on va refaire la même on ne peut pas
vraiment au début
alors on va tenter ce truc marrant ça me
fascine je me faire chier gens perdent
la gagne que je voulais gagner quoi
bon alors oui c'est de remonter le roi
allez c'est de faire la même que tu as
leur ne fait jamais ça c'est très
mauvais mais c'est marrant encore
commencé à chasser les cases donc la
sortie on prend ra prend gérant des cats
essais vont rappelle qu'on joue au king
of the hill canal et m6 semble être le
bon cours
ah merde y'a maths en deux temps quand
ils le voient pas y'avait dame prend des
quatre matches je repars je redescends
alors est-ce que je vais pouvoir
survivre
il a raté m'attendent oui montres leroy
maintenant aussi [ __ ] je suis dans le
caca jusqu'au cou
toi il ya ma tondeuse
merde jusqu'au cou je faire à 3 je vais
prendre du roi
je lui donnais un échec pour empêcher
avec la tour
l'action prend et roi des 4 il a raté
m'attendais
il faut qu'ils payent pour hockey double
échec sur la c5 dam des quatre matches
il avait m'attendre avant que j'ai raté
quelque chose moi même mais la dame
prend des cats et matin aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe aïe
l'union c'est quand même dommage de
rater m'attendre c'est très dommage je
pas qui c'est dans le chatt uneo c'est
peut-être gare king à artix garfinkel
salsa l'actros je fais un truc de fou à
cause sa pré ou dans le vilain ses
chances a tellement dommage pour les neo
il était tellement pas loin
il était vraiment à deux doigts de
l'emporter à l'union et nice et l'ol
c'est dommage dans l'une et au tt à une
encablure quoi tu avais le match a été à
une encablure voilà j'ai pas trop
compris le dr de parents fous qui m'a
filé la dame ont requis matou filet
alors est ce que j'en ai trop fait we
are attends je vais prendre la prendre
là je faire ces six et je vais monter
allez je monte
hero 5 imparable au prochain à non il
veut faire annuler pour le tournoi pas
de nul a pas lui donner de point ne
serait-ce 2020 et tant pis pour lui
passés maîtres yoyo qui c'est arrivé à
temps pour baron fou c'est toi qui perd
des points bas on fout hein c'est pas
moi c'est toi qui paie récupère des
points aurait pu mettre plus de points
en perdant en faisant nul après elle va
pas voir la news la partie va être adulé
mais ça fait plus perdus que moi en vrai
moi je vais jamais faire je n'ai jamais
accepté nul à un coût de de gagner donc
donc donc pas grave en dommages contre
l'allemand ca partira pas perdre ce
n'était pas loin
pourquoi il mais parce qu'il risque une
mini fuite dans le tournoi et donc ça
finira avant non à la loi c'est dans les
règles après jahan quand il ya autant de
points d'élodée car de toute façon à
moins de jouer pour la première place ou
quoi mais sinon j'ai plus de pages web
voyez plus adresse c'est sur mais bon
moi j'aurais fait pareil à sa place
contre un mec beaucoup plus fort
j'aurais fait pareil
bon après ça dépend contre un mec moins
fort j'aurais fait pareil qu'on
travaille plus fort précieux en mai
contre avec - forêt je joue le top 10
âgés ça fait pas perdre de place de
perle en fait cela fait perdre en fait
ya que toi qui est perdant de ce truc là
ce que tu aurais pu rejouer les parties
et faire des points donc envoya que toi
qui est perdante de ce truc là moi ça a
un peu mal et finit devant toi moi ça va
j'étais juste devant donc je pouvais
plus gagner vraiment de place ça aurait
pu se faire attraper ces paroles qui a
encore gagné mais coûte bravo oui c'est
un jeu proche de ses échecs c'est sympa
mais ça va barbie fait ce qu'il fait ce
qu'il veut donc non mais du coup à king
of the hill sympa sympa comme je trois
échecs j'ai pas aimé donc on fait on
fait un bilan rapide trois échecs
on n'a pas aimé enfin j'ai pas aimé vous
faites comme vous voulez 960 on aime
bien crise yahoo sont aime bien roi de
la colline on aime bien moi pizza 4
j'aime pas donc en gros 3 sur 5 dans les
variantes on pourra faire et on a
classic web on verra avec faf demain il
fera 960 du goût et après on refera
classique que ça nous aura permis
d'essayer toutes les variantes du jeu
donc c'est quand même sympa ça m'a
permis de découvrir un peu d'autres
choses et je trouve que c'est cool je
trouve que comme je le disais je vais me
répéter pour la dixième fois vos yeux de
faire les title tuesday tous les mardis
avec le même jeu et voilà ça aurait été
cool de faire des evènes comme ça avec
des variantes pour découvrir d'autres
choses jouer à prendre tu vas faire du
try hard sur du crédit house sur des
choses comme ça ça aurait été super
sympa ça aurait été super sympa c'est
vraiment dommage de je trouve de
d'envoyer un et même à et même les
nouvel aréna de choses comme premium là
je passe il en a entendu parler ça
commence le 3 mai il y aura des prix
pour les moins de 800 pour les moins de
1000 pour les moins de 1200 ça aurait
été plus sympa du coup quitte à faire
quelque chose de toute façon avoir la
soirée était peut-être plus sympa de
faire de faire un peu des variantes des
choses un peu amusantes quoi
les lots sont proposés sur la 7ème posé
sur ma toile c'est des vrais règles sepa
direct le train la dérision un crise
yahoo soi et ça peut être mal sur un
full house est encore plus mal à l'aise
à 10 ans pèse pas je crois qu'il joue
bien en crédit à ousmane ancien je crois
qu'il joue bien aussi tout maintenant
créer sa hausse mais c'est peut-être
plus facile de vérifier mais quitte à
faire un petit evan tu t'es pas obligé
de mettre 1500 $ tu peux faire un petit
truc avec s'emballe juste comme ça pour
un peu chauffé tout le monde faire du
try hard les ordis son plus fort
maintenant avec les humains crise house
en toute façon mais bon je trouve ça
aurait été plus marrant que le title
tous des personnellement
samedi ça gère un an mais je joue plus
l'annoncé était cool bon bah écoute et
du coup de vin sera face à 960 puisque
lui c'est sa variante préférée
et là je vous souhaite à tous une bonne
journée on se retrouve à moi je suis
râle 19h sur le stream toujours de poker
julien martin il faudra retenir son nom
de 19 heures à 20 heures
et est ce soir 20h30 femme qui fera le
petit cours sur les cinq fils en achète
donc voilà écoutez merci d'avoir suivi
et on se retrouve ce soir